I’d like to dedicate this one to all the women in South Africa --
those women who refused to dwindle in the midst of apartheid.
And, of course, I’m dedicating it also to my grandmother,
whom I think really played quite a lot of important roles,
especially for me when I was an activist, and being harassed by the police.
You will recall that in 1976, June 16, the students of South Africa boycotted
the language of Afrikaans as the medium of the oppressor,
as they were sort of like really told
that they must do everything in Afrikaans --
biology, mathematics -- and what about our languages?
And the students wanted to speak to the government,
and police answered with bullets.
So every year, June 16, we will commemorate
all those comrades or students who died.
And I was very young then. I think I was 11 years,
and I started asking questions,
and that’s when my political education started.
And I joined, later on, the youth organization
under the African National Congress.
So as part of organizing this and whatever,
this commemoration, the police will round us up
as they call us leaders.
And I used to run away from home,
when I know that maybe the police might be coming
around the ninth or 10th of June or so.
And my grandmother one time said,
"No, look, you’re not going to run away.
This is your place, you stay here."
And indeed, the police came -- because they’ll just arrest us
and put us in jail and release us whenever they feel like, after the 20th or so.
So it was on the 10th of June, and they came, and they surrounded the house,
and my grandmother switched off all the lights in the house,
and opened the kitchen door.
And she said to them, "Vusi's here, and you're not going to take him tonight.
I'm tired of you having to come here, harassing us,
while your children are sleeping peacefully in your homes.
He is here, and you're not going to take him.
I've got a bowl full of boiling water -- the first one who comes in here, gets it."
And they left.
(Applause) (Music)